111 feet long 38 feet high and big
enough to carry a Blackhawk helicopter
kc-390 is a 23 tonne behemoth it could
be a game-changer for Brazilian
aerospace giant it's very exciting
really very exciting as the biggest
opening ever conceived and build an
empire in Brazil this is the biggest
airplane yes and you'll be a big girl
uh-huh yeah
embry are is Brazil's answer to Boeing
albeit smaller it dominates the regional
jet business worldwide and now sees huge
profit potential in military plane
why this move into the fence we look at
the scenario around us you know have
been doing business in Latin America in
Southeast Asia in Brazil and all of
those markets they are growing their
budget for the fast finally they are
paying attention that but relying on
emerging market with an unproven track
record in defense spending is a big risk
especially when sales four embryos
bread-and-butter business commercial
jets fell twenty percent in the first
quarter of 2013 but it's a gamble the
company's willing to take what kind of
revenue potential could this be four we
are talking about more than 50 50 50
billion u.s. dollars the plan offer the
kc-390 for a much lower price than its
competitor Lockheed Martin c-130
Hercules carries a price tag between 90
to 125 million dollars how is it that
you're able to produce something that in
your opinion of better quality but more
economical than what Lockheed would be
doing we are using new technologies for
both the product and the production
can you actually crashing technology
like an auto throttle system helps even
the most novice of pilots I'll write up
a downer avoid imminent disaster yes but
no he's correct embryo is banking on the
kc-390 to continue the growth of its
defense division which exceeded 1
billion dollars in revenue for the first
time in 2012 but that's still a far cry
from industry leader Lockheed Martin
whose defense sales top 13 billion how
big concern is not to be one of the
biggest guys constantly you're not going
to get there but who can be like the top
50
you